you get to go inside for the sound of
money this exhibition is relevant it's
relevant in terms of our country who
have taken the presidency probably
during a period of rough seas for the
European Union but it is also a moment
of of hope these kind of cultural
messages are even more more effective
than political messages and they
transmit exactly the message in a
shorter time and probably with more
credibility as well and it fits in
perfectly well with our major priorities
in migration but it's not all the
migration its neighbourhood policy which
is very essential at the moment there is
the geopolitical tensions that we're
facing now are very fundamental also to
the future of the European Union its
maritime affairs also when it comes to
security because we have to address also
the external border of the Mediterranean
our approach is going to be a pragmatic
one we know it's not for sending all the
difficulties and we know that Europe is
being challenged at the moment it's
being challenged on various dimensions
however we feel that we are optimistic
that it has enough resilience it has
enough strength internal strength to
turn the setbacks that we're facing at
the moment into a positive outcome we
will do our utmost I think everybody
here because we do believe in the future
of the European project especially I
personally do believe in the future of
this project because I do believe in our
use in your revenues because ultimately
it's the future generation that will
give that will give an impetus a
momentum to a new European
you